[Music]
on this wednesday night a warning for
protesters in ottawa police say get out
now or face arrest no i'll stay wherever
i want
plus the political debate over whether
the emergencies act is necessary the
prime minister has not provided any
legal justification the threshold was
met for the emergencies act
russia claims it's pulling back troops
from near ukraine nato says not true
we are at a pivotal moment
in the history of ukraine
europe
and global stability we're on the ground
in eastern poland as western allies meet
and universal donor organs the canadian
experiment that could revolutionize
transplant surgery
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
the prime minister and federal cabinet
ministers are defending their decision
to invoke the emergencies act and police
in ottawa are now handing out warnings
to people who have been allowed to
occupy the area next to parliament hill
for almost three weeks now you must
leave the area now police warn anyone
blocking streets or assisting others in
the blocking of streets or committing a
criminal offense and you may be arrested
you must immediately cease further
unlawful activity or you will face
charges
and for the first time since these
protests began the government connected
the organizers of the ottawa protest
with those arrested in kutz alberta four
of whom are charged with conspiracy to
commit murder and the seizure by the
rcmp of a cache of weapons and
ammunition
several of the individuals at kutz
have strong ties
to a far right extreme organization with
leaders who are in ottawa
we're talking about a group
that is organized
agile
knowledgeable and driven by an extremist
ideology
where might makes right
when asked if he has clear evidence of
any direct ties the minister would only
say the groups share the same rhetoric
and ideology we will get to more on all
of that in just a moment but we begin
with what's happening near parliament
hill abigail beeman starts off our
coverage tonight
this isn't going against the law some
protesters didn't mind telling police
they weren't happy with these warnings
what about the people of waterloo i'm a
person of ottawa others stuck them here
by late afternoon the warning seemed to
turn just a few wheels but didn't stop
the street pig roast
northern noise even though a judge just
extended the injunction against honking
don't need to go and arrest these people
and make these truck goes out we need a
prime minister to put his boots on come
and walk and talk with us peacefully we
don't want to hurt him protesters remain
defiant a police warning doesn't change
things a criminal fence i don't think
it's a criminal offense to be here
protesting this is just fear-mongering
we are peaceful came two weeks ago and
then we're coming back again on this
weekend celina halma says she was fired
from her nursing job at an ontario
hospital for not declaring her
vaccination status i'm not scared of
being here because
it's peaceful b this is what we stand
for and it's no time to step down now
the new police chief warned what's to
come will be something people in ottawa
are not used to seeing and the local
children's aid society put out a warning
urging parents to make alternate child
care arrangements in case they're not
able to care for their children after
any police activity cas promising to
help reunite families if kids and
parents get separated boy i'd like to
get into one hell of a fight
but they're using their children as
human shields out there to try to keep
us from doing our job which is
protecting canadians it's disgraceful
under the order canadians continue to be
allowed to come to ottawa with their
children if they choose to engage in
peaceful lawful protest protest
organizers push back against the
government continuing to call for more
backup please come
your country needs you
and we need your support but calling
this a press conference
thank you guys
to get up and leave without answering a
single question abigail beeman global
news ottawa
the emergencies act is now in force but
must be debated and voted on in
parliament that debate begins tomorrow
it's required by law part of the
oversight required so that no government
can overreach its powers the scope of
those powers casts a wide net of
criminal liability david aiken looks at
what's covered by this emergency order
and how the political debate about it is
shaping up david
donna the powers detailed in the
emergencies act are broad and they could
apply right across the country
blockades or unlawful assemblies are
prohibited at all border crossings all
airports all harbors ports power
stations hospitals and so on an
exhaustive list of infrastructure assets
those who have gathered at the
parliamentary precinct are now by law
participating in an unlawful assembly
and face increased fines imprisonment or
other sanctions and anyone thinking of
joining the ottawa protest this long
weekend faces the same and at worst
you may be tying yourself to dangerous
criminal activity
it is also now illegal to bring a child
to an unlawful assembly and that's a big
deal because lots of parents have
already brought their kids to the
parliament hill occupation and the
presence of those children makes things
a lot trickier for law enforcement all
of these emergency act provisions will
automatically expire in 30 days unless
extended by the government notably it
will be up to local police forces not
politicians to decide when and where an
assembly or blockade is unlawful but
that means the emergencies act could
apply to blockades or protests in
provinces such as alberta and quebec
where there are premiers who oppose the
use of the emergencies act senators and
mps will debate and vote on these
measures later this week the black
quebecois and the conservatives will
vote against hoping to end the measures
the prime minister has not provided any
legal justification for the use of the
emergencies act a historic unfettered
power grab but the ndp are expected to
vote in favor agreeing with the liberal
rationale the measures that we've
brought forward
are targeted
temporary
and proportionate to the threat that
exists in our country now the vote in
the senate could be a bit of a wild card
in any event as politicians begin a
debate it's worth noting that the only
place right now in the entire country
where there is an illegal blockade or
protest subject to the emergencies act
is right here on parliament hill
donna
all right david aiken on parliament hill
tonight thanks
yeah the blockade near the u.s border in
kutz alberta is over 13 people were
arrested in connection with that event
four of them are charged with conspiracy
to commit murder canada's public safety
minister linked those arrested to
organizers of the ottawa protest and
says the illegal blockades posed a
threat to national security tracy nagai
reports on the ongoing investigation
while the blockade at the coots border
crossing is gone the investigation into
those responsible for it is ramping up
with police now digging into what's
being described as a small organized
group of protesters with a militant
mindset and the ability to get their
hands on these
long guns handguns ammunition and body
armor the dangerous criminal activity
occurring away from the tv cameras and
social media posts was real and
organized
and it could have been deadly for
citizens protesters and officers among
the 13 people arrested four face the
most serious charges of conspiracy to
commit murder accused of plotting to
murder rcmp officers in connection with
the protest we're talking about a group
that is organized
agile
knowledgeable and driven by an extremist
ideology we need police officers as well
who will have the courage to resist
unlawful orders and global news has
learned some protesters intended to
expand their efforts all the way to
ottawa if the government of alberta
thinks that the protest is over and the
threat is gone
then they're more more naive than i even
thought neil lemay is a retired mountie
with 30 years of policing experience his
security firm found some protesters so
emboldened they discussed targeting
critical infrastructure nationally
including airport cargo terminals and
leaning into religion and far-right
ideologies to recruit it is extensively
quoting the bible for justifications to
take up arms against the government to
overthrow the government right now
alberta rcmp releasing few details about
those charged or whether there may be
more arrests to come
trace negai global news calgary
in southern manitoba rcmp say highway 75
is now clear of protesters and traffic
is flowing at the border crossing in
emerson farm equipment semi-trucks and
other vehicles packed up and rolled out
today escorted by the rcmp
officers say they made a deal with the
protesters to end the blockade which
started last thursday
we're going to have nobody charged
nothing towed nobody injured no arrest
it's a perfect solution
rcmp say they'll keep a presence in
emerson to help ensure traffic keeps
moving the disruption cost more than 70
million dollars a day in cross-border
trade
well the economy has taken a major hit
from the blockades and from covid19 the
inflation rate surged to a 30-year high
last month the rate climbed to 5.1
percent in january the cost of almost
everything is going up especially
housing groceries and gas driven in part
by stress on supply chains fuel prices
jumped more than 31 percent last month
over what they were a year ago
rising inflation will put more pressure
on the bank of canada to hike interest
rates possibly as early as the beginning
of march
no signs of de-escalation coming up we
take you to eastern europe as nato
allies examine how to bolster defenses
against russia
there are more mixed signals about what
russia is planning in ukraine moscow
claims it's pulling back some of its
forces from the ukrainian border but
nato and ukraine say they've seen no
signs of de-escalation they say there is
evidence the kremlin is adding troops as
jackson proskow explains the white house
is warning of a fresh attempt by russia
to create a pretext for an invasion
ukraine had declared this a day of
national unity the day the west had
warned russia might mount a large scale
of salt
but the only military action came in the
form of drills overseen by president
vladimir zelinsky ukrainians practiced
firing american-made anti-tank missiles
and bombing runs meant to take out a
column of invading russian tanks
we are not afraid of any people of any
enemies zalenski told the troops
moscow may have blinked for now at least
that's the claim
russia released video of some of its
troops and tanks returning to bases
few believe it's any kind of meaningful
de-escalation we continue to see
critical units moving toward the border
not away from the border nato defense
ministers remain deeply cautious
unwilling to trust russia until they can
verify its intent we look forward to
seeing evidence of the withdrawal of
troops on russia's part but we need to
prepare for any eventuality
what russia does is more important than
what it says and russian media report
the country is suddenly investigating
what it claims are mass graves in the
disputed pro-russian region of donbass
where vladimir putin this week claimed
genocide is taking place
the white house warns it could all be an
excuse for putin to launch military
action there could be a range of
false flags and pretext that we would
expect would precede
an invasion though the kremlin denies
responsibility ukraine is already
navigating one of the worst cyber
attacks in its history it took down
banks and government websites
it has not ended the resolve of the
ukrainian people to defend their country
tonight the warnings about an imminent
attack are growing stronger the u.s
believes russian troops may have moved
into fighting position and the uk warns
the russian military is building field
hospitals to treat wounded soldiers
donna
all right jackson thank you nato
countries in eastern europe are on high
alert poland shares a border with
ukraine and is a nato member and that's
where thousands of soldiers have been
sent our europe bureau chief crystal
gamansing is in southeast poland tonight
crystal
donna american soldiers here in
southeastern poland are hard to miss
throughout the day we saw convoys of
military vehicles headed to a makeshift
base about an hour away and chinook
helicopters overhead
there's urgency as americans move into
poland strengthening nato's eastern
flank
thousands of personnel some just arrived
preparing for a russian escalation
or invasion there's been a flurry of
activity here at this staging area we
have seen numerous humvees coming and
going at least a half a dozen raf semi
coaches taking soldiers to and from this
location both american soldiers we've
seen as well as polish soldiers
they're here to ensure the safety of
those living in this and other nato
countries but their presence underscores
the potential for war this is so
very frightening
and
kind of sad so
i'm a little afraid about this
from this part of southeastern poland
it's only about an hour's drive to the
ukrainian border between neighbors the
greatest needs are known urgent medical
care and housing for refugees will need
to be prioritized if there's an invasion
says ukraine's ambassador they don't
know how many they can
adopt
the ukrainians
but uh i'm trying we are trying to
convince them that we will do
our best
not to
uh
create a situation
when ukrainians
will have to flee the country
fighting in the donbass region has been
going on for years but when war first
broke out between ukraine and
pro-russian separatists in 2014 hundreds
sought safety in poland some analysts
fear the territory could be used as a
bargaining chip along with ukraine's
desire to join nato it can seem to some
of our western allies
to be
an appropriate compromise
in order to stop
the worst possible scenario like
real war those issues are critical to
ukraine's future and to many
too big to abandon
donna
all right crystal gomezing in poland
tonight thanks
[Music]
cryptocurrency concerns the federal
government's crackdown on the money
fueling the ottawa protests may hit a
roadblock
following the money donated to support
the disruptive protests that have
happened in canada is complicated with
the emergencies act now invoked the
federal government says the police and
the banks have the authority to stop the
flow of cash as ann gaviola explains
that means more than just traditional
forms of currency
the lifeblood of this protest is the
funding behind it organizers have raised
more than 10 million dollars first on
crowdfunding platform gofundme then over
give send go but it's been one obstacle
after another for protesters to actually
get the money on monday sweeping changes
targeting banks and crowdfunding
platforms were announced under the
emergencies act these changes cover all
forms of transactions
including digital assets
such as cryptocurrencies what the world
has witnessed here
is the power of government
to manipulate
the flows of people's hard-earned
dollars all of this driving the movement
to bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
and even digital assets like nfts
anti-money laundering experts tell
global news these fall into a gray area
crypto experts say cracking down on
bitcoin itself is complicated but
authorities have an opportunity to act
when that crypto is turned into cash
gift cards or prepaid cards this
forensic accountant is waiting to find
out more about what specifically is
covered under the emergencies act once
it makes its way through parliament this
is a fascinating shift
and it provides lots of powers in
financial institutions that you know i'm
not sure is is uh
not sure is a great thing for the long
term alex tapscott's specialty is
blockchain the technology that underpins
bitcoin he warns of unintended
consequences with the spotlight on
bitcoin and other digital assets let's
not throw the baby out with the bath
water let's take a cautious and
deliberate approach to regulating any
new technology that comes along the
concern among technologists is that
temporary new rules put in place during
an emergency could eventually be adopted
and hinder economic growth and
innovation in fintech long after this
convoy is cleared out
donna
all right ann gaviola
thanks
next the canadian experiment that could
change organ transplants and save more
lives
a dream olympic send-off for canadian
speed skater charles amela the 37 year
old helped his teammates win gold in the
men's 5 000 meter short track relay this
is the sixth career medal for amele
making him canada's most decorated male
winter olympian
he's expected to retire later this year
and for the first time in 16 years
canada's men's hockey team is heading
home from the olympics without a medal
sweden beat the canadian men's team
today canada still has a chance for
olympic hockey gold though the women's
team faces off against the united states
tonight
well from athletic feats to what could
be a big step forward in organ
transplants there is a shortage of donor
organs many people die waiting for one
and people with rare blood types have an
even smaller chance of getting one that
matches their blood type canadian
researchers are working to change that
by changing the blood itself jamie
morocco explains
elizabeth ostrander spent the majority
of the pandemic two years waiting for a
lung transplant i was getting a little
bit frustrated and
just
depressed about you know
not getting the match
the weight is excruciating and can be
extended for those with certain blood
types if i have someone that is very
sick and for example is an old blood
type and i get a
b or a donor offer
for transplantation i cannot transplant
that patient dr marcelo saipel and his
team are trying to level the playing
field in a new experiment the first of
its kind they say they've converted
donor lungs with one blood type to a
universal type then patient in need of a
organ transplant
would have access
to
all the organs regardless of their blood
type
blood type is determined by the presence
of antigens on the surface of the red
blood cells in our bodies type a has the
a antigen b has b
a b has both a and b and type o the
universal blood type has none
saipel needed to clear any antigens from
the organs and stephen withers at the
university of british columbia had the
perfect enzyme the enzymes themselves
are ones that we discovered by hunting
within the human gut microbiome which in
reality means in human theses those
enzymes were injected into one lung from
a type a donor the other was left
untreated researchers then introduced
type o blood to both simulating what
would happen when an organ is
transplanted into a patient
and what we could see is that these
lungs did not present any signs
of rejection clinical trials are next
elizabeth who finally got her lung by
the way is hopeful
there'd be more transplants more organs
available potentially breathing new life
experts say into an unfair and outdated
system jamie morocco global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
york canada is francis saskatchewan
there are beautiful spots all over this
country please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Music]